it always seemed like Rob Dyrdek was
living the dream who wouldn't want to
make millions while competing in the
sport they love and goofing off with
their friends but recently he stepped
back from the spotlight here's what he's
been up to and why you won't catch him
on reality TV anymore in September 2015
dyrdek married his longtime girlfriend
Brianna Flores the two got engaged that
Disneyland resorts in April 2015 while
they were watching the Aladdin Show
dyrdek secretly snuck around backstage
and carried out a wild public proposal
that could have totally been a stunt on
Rob Dyrdek's Fantasy Factory he came out
on stage riding an elephant and asked
Flores to be his wife after enjoying a
romantic and extravagant baby moon in
Bora Bora the couple welcomed their
first child on September 9th 2016 a son
named Kota according to E news dyrdek
was ecstatic about becoming a father for
the first time in an Instagram post
about his wife he said in part as much
as I love this woman with all of my
being I could never express how proud I
am of how strong she is dyrdek and
Flores seem to be quite happy with
Parenthood and in December 2017 the
couple announced the arrival of their
second child a baby girl named Nala and
expressed their joy about giving Kota a
sibling and growing their family now in
his mid forties dyrdek waited until
later in life to start his family but he
was ready for a change along with the
announcement of the birth of his
daughter he shared on Instagram she is
an angel from heaven
she is absolute perfection she is our
princess dyrdek has admitted that he
prefers to maintain a stronger boundary
between his business and personal life
now than he did in the past and this
change has been a long time coming while
dyrdek was working on Rob and big he
didn't like the lack of privacy that
appearing on MTV afforded him after the
final season aired in 2008 MTV
originally approached dyrdek with a
prospect of shooting an additional
season but dyrdek knew it was time for
something different
he told thought Co my businesses were
being affected my skateboarding was
being affected and I hated that it was
being filmed at my house so once we had
a little break it evolved I thought what
if I added a skate park to my business
thus Rob Dyrdek's Fantasy Factory was
born and dyrdek could finally keep his
home life
and his reality TV shenanigans separate
dyrdek told founder that eventually
working in reality TV just took too much
out of him he wanted to put all of that
time toward his other professional
interests he added that reality TV
didn't give him the same return on
energy that building businesses brought
him so we decided to switch up his
priorities he clearly isn't done with TV
appearances after all dyrdek has his
show ridiculousness but when it comes to
his involvement with ridiculousness
most of his responsibilities center
around discovering and curating
hilarious content for the show which was
inspired by the format of America's
Funniest Home Videos despite struggling
to reconcile their differences
off-camera while filming the later
seasons of Rob & big dyrdek and his
co-star Christopher big black Boykin
always shared a strong bond and years of
happy memories oh boy big black welcome
to a crib in 2017 big black shockingly
passed away after suffering a heart
attack at the age of 45 naturally dyrdek
was devastated and needed time to grieve
the loss the two had been inseparable
for years and even after they decided
that it was time to close the door on
Rob and big big black still made
appearances on Fantasy Factory
dyrdek shared his thoughts on the loss
of his friend on social media tweeting
my heart is broken I don't want to write
this post I don't want to believe that
this is reality I am so thankful for you
overall it seems dyrdek has allowed
himself to fade out of the spotlight by
choice although he has fun on the set of
ridiculousness he isn't looking to be
the star of the show anymore he'd rather
be the guy pulling the levers behind the
curtain he told Forbes anytime an
opportunity presents itself really what
I'm trying to do is put an
infrastructure around me to creatively
operate at a very high level and be able
to have the people who can execute the
idea I operate best on big vision and
creative detail aside from hosting
ridiculousness dyrdek says his true
passion is for entrepreneurship so he
can also be the genius behind some of
your new favorite brands and products
nowadays he seems to be doing a little
bit of everything and he's loving it
check out one of our newest videos right
here Plus even more looper videos about
your favorite shows are coming soon
subscribe to our YouTube channel
and hit the bell so you don't miss a
single one
[Music]